we bring in the great David fatty he's
contributing to Golf Channel and NBC
Sports live tournament coverage 148 Open
Championship taking place at royal
Portrush a native of northern island and
grew up just a short drive from Port
rush I don't know if it's like a Brooks
kept good drive or maybe a Corey Pavin
Drive live coverage to the 148 open airs
on Golf Channel and NBC that's today
through Sunday live coverage of the
first round Arizona Golf Channel in fact
it's on right now
second round beginning Thursday night at
1:30 a.m. Eastern good morning David how
are you today I'm great thanks daddy
thanks for having me on okay how far
away did you live from this golf course
royal Portrush 15 minutes from this one
okay it's if I told you if I told you 20
years ago 15 years ago ten years ago
that royal Portrush was going to host
the Open Championship what would you
have said I would say you know you'd
lost your mind I never thought I'd see
it in my lifetime then but when you talk
about you know the locals there talk
about the troubles how bad do you think
how bad was it because I never visited
Northern Ireland I'd stopped at Dublin
but what what was it like and what is it
like now in Northern Ireland well the
trouble is the most recent version of
them you know because there's been
trouble brewing in Ireland you know
since 1690 and it's was a day after my
11th birthday in 1969 the really sort of
kicked off and you know I lived in an
area that wasn't particularly touched by
it but I was only a few miles from from
where it was pretty bad that's for sure
and we lost nearly 4,000 people over the
kind of 30 years that the the main
difficulties were and I you know we
would hear explosions and I actually
worked at Balmoral Golf Club as an
assistant which is in the really in the
war zone
in Belfast and we hear explosions pretty
much every day there were no Street
roadblocks and riots and I mean it was
an interesting was an interesting time
how did they get the open well I think
that you know from the signing of the
Good Friday Agreement in 1998 you know
the province has been considerably more
peaceful and it's with big sporting
events these days security is always a
concern no matter where in the world it
is so I think they are and I looked at
and you know royal Portrush is such a
jewel of a golf course it was about time
you know that you know the British Open
came back came back to this particular
part of the UK he's David Feherty and I
wanted to look and see what your career
was at the Open Championship you you
played in 12 missed you missed the cut
six times yeah top ten twice at Royal
Troon and Turnberry
yeah okay but do you wonder if could you
have had your personality now with that
David Feherty would you have been a
better golfer yes yeah there's no
question you know hindsight is 20/20
done I mean I think most people look
back and think well you know if it'd
been that way or I've been this way you
know it's the older you get now I'm
trying to tell my 21 year old daughter
at the minute you know when I was 16 I
thought I knew everything you know and
then I realize that you know I didn't
know anything when I was 16 well that
doesn't change it just keeps going like
that until you lose your marbles Rory
McIlroy a lot of pressure going into
this week and I think you were either
all-in with Rory being the guy to beat
or there was too much pressure of his
home course and we saw that from the
first hole where he had an 8 how does
that happen with a guy like Rory on a
course he's played hundreds of times and
you end up with an 8 on the first hole
at your home course in the Open
Championship yeah that's a good question
there the first hole here grow up
progress there's Audubon's on each side
it is I mean it's not a particularly
difficult tee shot but when you consider
the sort of pressure that Rory is under
you know that the home time boy and the
enormous amount of support that he has
it was a huge roar when he gets up in
the first tee probably something I'm
like you know anything he's ever
experienced but the bonds with an iron
that's a that is not a particularly good
shot and then he nearly had about a bun
for the next one you know so he's back -
I think +3 is the minute you know if he
can get in fact you know close to par
he's by no means out of this but you
know starting with an 8 man hello I
suppose there's nowhere to go but up
but then David Duval had a 13 and I know
David doesn't play that that much
competitively but he had a 13 and it's
hard to look at you know watch something
like that when he used to be the best
golfer in the world oh yeah well I mean
he also threw an 8 in as well you know I
tell people it's always nice to have a 1
in your scorecard but you don't want a 3
after it but it just goes to show you I
mean it doesn't matter who you are
especially in links golf but he had an
episode where he played the wrong ball
and I think he played it more than once
so it was just a bizarre you know
episode that I mean it can happen to
anybody it doesn't happen very often but
there you go
I was watching the telecast this morning
and Nick Faldo talked about Tiger Woods
chances here and he said if the weather
was really warm then he would give Tiger
a better chance but you know how that
weather is an hour ago it was raining
and it was windy now it's sunny there
but what role does the weather play on
just the physicality of Tiger being able
to play these four rounds here in in
Northern Ireland
yeah I mean he doesn't have a terrific
track record and bad weather you get
some players
that that can just you know bring it to
another level and bad weather Tom Watson
was maybe the greatest bad wire weather
player of all time Sandy Lyle it was
another one when he had his waterproof
when he had water proofs on he was
generally in front or close to it
Tiger is you know he's susceptible to
you know the back issues obviously a
stiffness and you know anytime you're
playing in cold or damp or weather that
can be an issue and Brooks koepka I
don't know if people it felt like they
were on the edge of if was he gonna be
great if you because you can't overpower
these kind of golf courses I don't think
I don't know what royal Portrush is like
far more lush and not dried out like
some of these other link style courses
or but Brooks kept cos chances are what
in your opinion I think he's got an
because you know he has tremendous power
but he knows when to use it you'll see a
lot of irons and unfair way Woods from
from tees here at royal Portrush it's
not the longest golf course plan about
72 and a half I think it's but it you
really need to think about where you're
leaving it you almost have to play the
golf course backwards in your head you
know where do I want to put this so I
can play the next shot and you know he
you don't win - yes opens in a row with
I've been able to figure your way around
a technical golf course so you know I
think he's got a great chance Tiger said
that he reached out to cap K I wanted to
play a practice round and we had Amanda
Bally Onis from CBS golf and team
Callaway yesterday and I asked her that
and she goes no Tiger didn't care about
being with Brooks he wanted to be with
Brooks his caddie who grew up on this
golf course what do you make of of Kefka
ghosting Tiger and not returning his
text yeah I'm not sure what went on
there but Rickey Elliott is he's from my
hometown in Bangor and has been around
this golf course oh god I don't know how
many times he's a fantastic caddie and
yeah
I can see hurry I can see you know the
tiger might might want to you know pick
his brain or have rather it would be
more like it at his caddy you know would
pick his brain
if we were in Northern Ireland what are
we eating Oh fish and chips you can
still get them served and they'll in the
newspaper you know with plenty of salt
and vinegar yeah there's a Irish stew
you know but the cuisine here has become
considerably more sophisticated over the
years but you have to have an area an
Ulster fry for breakfast there would be
bacon sausage eggs fried soda bread
potato bread and possibly baked beans
thrown in there as well and a different
world later did you know it sound like
somebody's squeak Tom behind there do
you still have that fart bag that used
to carry around with you on a rubber
chicken which also made a farting noise
and we've come on his car the rubber
chicken in my bag what do you think
about this a cop show said in Great
Britain and we call it bangers and mash
those are the two characters yeah yes
like Colin Colin Farrell and then I
don't know throw in somebody else who
else would you throw in there oh let's
see I think he'd be bangers you know you
know you're the female know they're you
know okay so thanks man oh yeah yeah who
would me I'm trying to think of an Irish
actress that would would do it you know
I we throw in Sinead O'Connor she would
be mosh nan mash no no we can't make
maybe Cersei Ronan
then Oh Saoirse Ronan yes yeah it should
be terrific yeah I'm so hey have fun
today as always and a pretty proud
moment I'm guessing for those folks in
Northern Ireland that the Open
Championship is back so hopefully it is
a great tournament but that we all
expect and we appreciate your time as
always David yeah thanks wait that's
David Feherty NBC sports golf part of
Golf Channel and NBC Sports live
tournament coverage for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]